we have many videos on khan academy on
things like evolution and natural
selection we think we have a fairly
solid understanding of how life can
evolve to give us the variety the
diversity that we've and the complexity
that we've seen around us but it still
leaves unanswered a very fundamental
question and this might be the biggest
question known to us and that is the
origins of life how did life first
emerge at least on earth and that even
starts to lead to other questions about
is there life outside of this planet and
what could it be like and so let's start
with what we actually know and i'm going
to start with a timeline
so
let's go 1 billion years ago let's go 2
billion years ago
3 billion years ago
four billion years ago so this is now
and once again we're talking about
billion years ago you'll sometimes see
the abbreviation bya billion years ago
which is a it's it's an unfathomable
amount of time going going into the past
but we know that earth along with the
rest of the solar system was formed
around 4.6
4.6 billion
years ago so that's when earth was
formed and
right at 4.6 or even you know you ate a
casual 100 million years after that 4.5
billion years ago we believe that earth
wasn't very suitable for even very
simple life to form and that's because
the solar system was a crazy place you
had collisions of all scales happening
all of the time
the moon itself was formed from the
collision of of two planet-sized objects
one would kind of call it the
proto-earth and and another planet-sized
object and they collided and then they
started to spin around and one part
became the moon they became it was
tidally tidally linked with the earth
but you could imagine that's not an
environment where it would be easy for
life to form and even once the moon was
formed you had a heavy bombardment of of
of of things contin in the solar system
the solar system was a messy place it
took a long time for the stability that
we now observe out there
and so that continued we believe until
about 3.9 billion years ago
which is the earliest that we currently
think that earth
might have been suitable for life before
that there might have been pockets where
the bombardment stop
stops and maybe some type of primitive
life might have formed but then they
would have gone away
with the heavy bombardment but who knows
maybe they could have survived that
somehow but that's that's the current
mainstream belief
the other thing we know is that we see
fossil evidence for life 3.5 billion
years ago
and these are stromatolites the fossil
evidence microorganisms they form these
structures
that actually are continue to be formed
today these types of these types of
structures continue to be formed today
and although it might not feel like
microorganisms or complex life when you
think about what has to happen within a
microorganism they are actually
incredibly complex especially if you
compare them to very simple
non-living organisms
so we our current belief is well
someplace in
some place in this region
life must have arisen on earth but that
still doesn't even if we were able to
answer that question oh it was exactly
3.7 billion years ago was the first time
that some rna decided to we're not
decided or ended up
getting in the right confirmation so it
could replicate itself in some away even
if we even if we know that date
it still leaves unanswered maybe the
most more interesting question which is
the how the how is really at least to me
more import more interesting than the
when
and to the how question there's a couple
of layers on it the first is well let's
just start with the most simple
molecules that we would have expected to
found to find on early earth here's some
examples of it right over here this is
h2o or more commonly known as water
right over here is co2 more commonly
known as
carbon that's a little hard to see let
me do a lighter a lighter
color
so we have
we have
carbon dioxide right over here here we
have molecular nitrogen you have some
ammonia you have some phosphate these
are and many other of the the elements
that we see on earth today they would
they might have been available in that
early earth
but how how do they form at least even
the the next step up which is the
slightly more complex or actually a good
bit more complex organic molecules and
when people talk about organic molecules
they might be talking about things like
this these are amino acids these are the
building blocks of proteins
amino acids
you see over here nucleotides these are
the building blocks of rna dna other
things
and so the first question is and these
aren't the only simple organic molecules
you could think about sugars and all
sorts of other things
but the question is
is it realistic can how do we at least
understand how we can go from these very
simple molecules up here to these more
complex often called organic molecules
and the simple answer is we now have a
lot of evidence that this is doable that
you can go from these things to these
things
abiotically and without the presence of
without the presence of life you'll hear
that word abiotic a lot think about it
antibiotic you're killing life you're
killing bacteria abiotic that is without
life
and the points of evidence that we now
have
are
we believe and we've seen evidence that
there are there's amino acids and and
organic molecules related to them on
comets meteorites on other planets that
it could they formed spontaneously in
space once again without the presence of
life there we've even been able to form
amino acids and other molecules like
this from these more simple elements in
the laboratory the most famous
experiment there is the miller and urex
yuri experiment this was in the 1950s
where they were able to show with with
some energy they provided a spark you
could imagine that in the early early
earth it could have been from lightning
and they tried to set up a a mix of
gases that they believed was similar to
the mix of the atmospheric mix in the
early earth which didn't have much
oxygen in the atmosphere then
we needed life to actually start to
produce some of that oxygen and even
though today we think that they probably
didn't have the mix of gases right they
were they did do something significant
they were able to show that with that
with that mix of gases at least they
thought were in that atmosphere and some
energy being added to that system that
they were able to form some of these
organic molecules
so we should feel pretty good that at
least this first step is doable
now the next question is well these
organic molecules by themselves that's
not life in fact these aren't even the
most complex molecules that are we
believe essential for life
proteins are where things start to get
really interesting and a protein
a protein
or proteins are one of the places a
protein might have thousands of amino
acids
thousands
of amino
amino acids things like dna and rna also
we believe essential for life or at
least life as we know it
could be made up of tens of millions of
nucleotides for one dna molecule so for
example this is this is just a small
part of a dna molecule but you can
already see much much more complex than
what we what we see over here
and there too we have evidence that you
can go from the amino acids to the
proteins or you can go from the
nucleotides to the dna without the
presence of life that these things can
happen spontaneously if you have the
right context the right energy available
some people believe or or it's been
observed that if you have
the right surfaces that these molecules
can be organized in the right way to
form these more complex things
now i know what you're thinking all
right
proteins are really cool dna rna is
really cool but then how does that
become life what what point would we
start counting well that was a that was
a proto-life form and this is where
we really get into the area of the
unknown because we don't know and
there's a couple of hypotheses out there
one of them is called the rna world
hypothesis i'll write that down rna
world
hypothesis
and this is the idea that the first
proto-life was self-replicating rna
molecules and the reason why people tend
to focus in on rna a little bit more
than dna is that even in cells today rna
doesn't just store information it can
actually play a a role as a catalyst
when you think about things like trna
and you think about ribosomal rna and so
maybe some of that first proto-life was
rna that information that replicated
itself and catalyzed the replication of
itself maybe it somehow got organized
into membrane-bound structures so it
could separate so you had environments
that were separated from the outside
world but the simple answer is we don't
know
another mainstream hypothesis is the
metabolism first hypothesis
metabolism
metabolism first
and this is the idea that a lot of a lot
of basic pathways that you might study
in say a biochemistry book that these
were kind of first just happening in in
well all of this could have been
happening in this primordial soup where
you had these organic molecules and in
the right conditions maybe around heat
vents and whatever else but the
metabolism first is that some of these
mechanisms that we now study in
biochemistry these might have happened
outside of a cell or outside of life and
they just kept creating more and more
complexity but at some point these
things started happening in in kind of
self-organizing membrane-bound
structures maybe there's some kind of
combination of the two the simple answer
is we just don't know but there's some
fascinating clues even if we observe
current biology in fact even if we see
the commonalities of of things that
happen central dogma of biology if we we
if we see how proteins which proteins
which which structures are common to all
life as we know it it might give us
clues or hints at what some of that very
earliest life or proto-life was actually
like